[Music]
so what's the deal with this banksy
story
um there's some girl i saw some tick
tock from some girl that was like i
can't believe i think i have two
banksies did you hear about that um is
it is that what this story is
this is kind of coherent i'm like
shaking and maybe i'm just gonna make
myself look like an absolute idiot and
people will be making fun of people like
me on the news or
yes
one tick tock soon but
i i don't know i just i can't stop
shaking at the the chance that maybe
this is real
i was just on my way home from work and
i had to say why why why why when people
do this [ __ ] and they tell these stories
in the mirror what's with the zooming
yeah the zooming and the cuts too yeah
just just say it face to camera yeah
yeah
i was just on my way home from work and
i had to switch trains um i live in new
york city mission failed we'll come next
time
okay we know you live in new york city
let's head to east side and i was going
to
me packing i was just going like my much
cooler apartment it's like there's no
rats in it like i have i live in the
apartment building with no rats
this is my outfit anyway and
um i had to switch trains at one of the
stops
um
and i passed this art exhibit in the
subway station
that was just like the
banksy exhibits or the banksy sales from
like london and other times he was in
new york and his exhibit is coming up
it's opening very soon
um
i was just reading about it and i really
want to go see his new york exhibit
because i like art
okay
this they they were just like pieces of
art did she just
[Laughter]
i'm going in she just panned the [ __ ]
camera down on her shoes to like
simulate looking down at art but there's
no [ __ ] art there
she just showed us that she has yeezys
scattered on the subway not on the train
but at the subway stop floor like no
tarp no plastic nothing protecting them
just on the floor with a piece of
caution tape around it and i didn't want
to film because i i just i respect you
know if it was banksy if it was him i i
didn't want to you know make too light
of it so i didn't film it but
i i was like wow that's amazing and it
was his classic like
uh cash or bitcoin only this is not a
photo opportunity like signs
and
there was nobody there i looked around i
literally i looked left and right and
there was nobody there these paintings
were just over there
and then i looked right i looked left
she panicked i don't know she passed it
like [ __ ]
louis
pam's right she's a view of the city
i looked left i looked right and
people could have just taken where you
could just picked one up and ran so i
got on my second train and i went home
and i made it all the way home
and my stomach just hurts so bad i ate
this one of one burrito i feel bad i
feel bad i know i know i know then i
took a huge [ __ ] and i decided to
take the train back because i ate this
like one of a kind cheese there's only
one of 20 wheels and it's because it was
on the west side
and i have exclusive access to this this
cheese tasting party
and i'm thinking oh that shit's so bad
he's tasting party
something in me was like go back
something in me was like no more gouda
so i literally got off my train
stopped at the first atm i could find
took out you know as much as i took 23
000
[Laughter]
i maxed out the atm i had to call garda
to bring more cash to the atm i drained
that whole bag so then i put 80k
in the gucci purse you might have saw it
when i was telling you i looked left it
was in that bag right there and i got
back on the train because i live in new
york
and i rode the train and i literally got
back on the train it's 10 o'clock at
night i have work tomorrow morning
it's 10 o'clock at night i got back on
goldman sachs by the way
train i went
back to the west side from the east side
like who would ever want to go back
there
and i was just praying that it would
still be there
nobody was paying attention the first
time i passed it everyone was just
walking by so when i got back a couple
people had stopped and were looking and
i looked around and somebody gave god
kind of a slight nod and i see this guy
just standing
full face covered ski mask like and i
went up to him and i was like are you
selling those
and he just nodded he wouldn't talk he
did not speak he just nodded yes and he
walked me over to them and i gave him
the money and i said i'll take two
and now here they are
and again maybe i'm just gonna sound
like an absolute idiot but and in
classic tick tock fashion whoever sees
us they're gonna scroll down two tick
tocks there's gonna be some dude who's
like yeah man so uh i put on this whole
thing no i didn't want to say that
banksy exhibit
uh this chick gave me like forty
thousand dollars for this [ __ ] you guys
don't understand how easy it is to mock
a banksy painting so uh like for a part
two i'll show you how to
make it
yeah so apparently banksy commented
is that the actual banksy account
what does it say yeah banksy yeah but is
it verified would banksy want a verified
account to save like a verified you just
have to assume every banksy thing is
fake so on the back it has a stamp that
says unauthorized which is supposedly
makes this more legit because that's the
name of his next uh exhibit in new york
and on the back
so amazing
someone wrote deez nuts
and i think it was him i think it was
banksy
[Laughter]
this sounds like the perfect scam for
someone to do
in a city where a banksy exhibit is
coming up yeah and people know about it
yeah and they know what he does in the
other cities where he's done similar
events yeah it sounds like the [ __ ]
perfect scam yeah take a stencil you
stencil a white canvas and then you
stand there with a mask and you naughty
people yeah not to say it maybe maybe it
is him i don't know they are unsigned
but on the back of one of them is
stamped unauthorized which is the name
of his upcoming exhibit when you go to
banksy's website to authenticate them it
will ask if it is signed or unsigned so
i know he does so unsigned
i love the the top comment like this is
when getting gas up on the internet is
so dangerous these are a hundred percent
real and you literally just became rich
it's like some random guy being like you
these are for sure it yeah you can quit
your job yes yes i've just appraised
them yeah tick-tock
and i can tell you that these are worth
millions that is a crazy come up though
no
if this was actually real which that but
isn't that the [ __ ] beauty of banksy
is you don't know
yeah what's real and what's not it's
like the entire point of his character
yeah and like uh you know like that that
piece he had sold however long ago where
it like auto shredded yeah exactly
it's like she'll never i mean i i guess
there probably is some way that you can
get these appraised and someone knows
the legit banksy style and probably can
tell what spray paint he uses and all
that stuff how could you even trust that
person though these are fake i should
take them off your hands yeah but if
they are real i mean what are these
worth like hundreds of thousands of
dollars she just ripped his mask
you off need him and then balls yeah and
ripped his mask he's for sale uh-huh
i [ __ ] knew it was you do it then you
just grab two of them [ __ ] off take five
pictures of his face and then grab two
and run out of there
i was gonna say as an update to the
shredded painting that you mentioned for
860 000
the guy who bought it bought it for 1.4
million and then it shredded
and then he it's now worth like 25
million
that's awesome he's just sitting there
like sick thank you thanks banks do you
own any art
um
nothing like crazy valuable
i have a couple paintings that are worth
like a couple grand by some artist
that's like famous on the west side you
um i did want to get a piece from this
artist uh i don't wanna butcher his last
name his first name is jolil and his
last name is spelt nzi and ga his art is
crazy as [ __ ] but then when i looked up
how much it was for an original i was
like whoa how much is it like 10 20 g's
dang wait can you bring up his art here
what's actually crazy is um
he uh
i believe he was in the pack
you know got my vans on
he's actually like
uh these are sick he's been in a lot of
love um
just like crucial moments in hip hop and
like rap music it's pretty crazy so but
his art is sick yeah it's really cool
so one day i would like to have an
original of his
the way he does this [ __ ] is dope and a
lot of these are massive like yeah uh
whoever's standing next to yeah these
are awesome gigantic pieces damn yeah
so shout out to jello man he uh he does
great [ __ ]
um i always watch his stories because
his lifestyle is just
just so cool yeah i know he just rolls
around in like a classic like green benz
and he'll just like the first frame
he'll be at like some art studio on the
next frame he'll be like asap rocky
you're
like nice
you